- [Narrator] Why do midterm
congressional elections matter?
- Congressional elections matter
because they are often
and have increasingly been
a referendum on the president.
So it is a kind of real test
from real voters doing real voting
about whether people approve
of what the president's doing
or disapprove of what he's doing.
But then there's also
an important question
of who has control of Congress?
If the president's party
has control of Congress
the way it's been working
in recent history is,
that means he's basically gonna get
a rubber stamp for what he wants to do.
If the president's party is
not in control of Congress
that means there are gonna
be more investigations
into the executive branch.
And that's of course what the
legislature is supposed to do
but it means more investigations,
it means that Congress might try
and pass its own legislation
and then work to some kind of
accommodation with the president.
Given the partisanship in
America right now though,
when you have the executive
in the control of one party
and the legislature in the
control of another party,
it also very well could
mean complete gridlock
and a situation in which
many of the nations
most important questions
don't get answered.